>> ♪ ♪
>> Sean: WE COME TO FROM YOU THE
SWAMP IS SEWER THAT IS
WASHINGTON, D.C.
JOINING US COUNSEL TO THE
PRESIDENT KELLYANNE CONWAY.
WE DIDN'T GIVE YOU ANY HEAT?
>> NO, FALSE ADVERTISING.
[LAUGHING].
>> Sean: WELCOME BACK.
THIS IS NOT SMALL.
YOU HAVE BEEN IN THE WHITE HOUSE
FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF THIS
COLLUSION NARRATIVE OF THE
IDIOTS ON THE NETWORK OF FAKE
NEWS.
>> COLLUSION DELUSION.
HERE WE ARE 6 MONTHS LATER
STILL.
IT'S A SERIOUS MATTER NOW, OF
COURSE.
>> Sean: WE KNOW THE FIX WAS IN
WE HAVE THE TEXT MESSAGES AND
HER PAID FOR DOSSIER WAS USED TO
THIS IS NOT FUN.
>> THE PRESIDENT WENT TO
QUANTICO LAST MONTH.
HE RESPECTS THE FBI AND THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO WORK HARD AND ARE
NOT INVOLVED IN THIS EPISODE.
AT THIS MOMENT, WE SHOULD LEAVE
YOUR GUESTS ARE DOING SO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN HAVE A
TRANSPARENT ACCOUNTABLE WAY TO
DECIDE WHAT THEY ARE SEEING.
THEY ARE FOCUSSING ON THAT MAN
IN THE WHITE HOUSE GIVING A
SPEECH TOMORROW.
>> Sean: I HAVE TO GO BACK TO
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE THROUGH THE
ROOF.
AND THE TAX PLAN KICKS IN
FEBRUARY 1.
>> KEEP GOING.
BEFORE IT KICKS IN, YOU HAVE 274
COMPANIES TAKING ACTION RELATED
TO THE TAX CUTS.
>> Sean: NO, THOSE ARE CRUMS.
>> THAT'S ACCORDING TO NANCY
PELOSI.
THEY ARE SO OUT OF TOUCH WITH
AMERICA.
TONIGHT THE SENATE REJECTED THE
ABILITY TO PUT INTO LAW A BILL
ABOUT ABORTIONS.
CALLING THAT CRUMBS, IT'S REAL
BREAD.
$2,000 BONUSES.
YOU SEE ALL OF THESE COMPANIES
REPATRIATING THEIR WEALTH TO
CREATE NEW JOBS.
OVER 200,000 MANUFACTURING JOBS
CREATED.
IN TENSE 2010 WHEN NANCY PELOSI
WAS THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
BARACK OBAMA ADMITTED THEY HAD A
SHELLACKING.
SO FAR OVER 3 MILLION AMERICANS
HAVE BENEFITTED FROM THE TAX
CUTS BECAUSE OF WHAT THEIR
EMPLOYERS HAVE DONE.
THE PRESSURE IS ON OTHER
OVERPULLS.
-- EMPLOYERS.
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
>> Sean: SINCE THE HISTORY OF
UNEMPLOYMENT.
THE LOWEST LEVEL FOR BLACK
AMERICANS AND HISPANIC AMERICANS
AND WOMEN.
EKE
EK
>> YOU DON'T HEAR IT BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE FOCUSSING ON OTHER
THINGS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
FOLKS KNOW THEIR CONFIDENCE IS
THE VALUE OF THEIR RETIREMENT
SAVINGS, THIS PRESIDENT'S TAX
BILL EXTEND THE SAVING PLAN TO
EARLIER.
>> Sean: GOTTEN VERY LITTLE
COVERAGE.
>> WE WILL TALK ABOUT THAT.
PEOPLE ASK ME HOW DO WE GET
WOMEN?
TALK ABOUT THE EDUCATION SAVING
EXPANSION.
THIS PRESIDENT BETWEEN THE
REGULATIONS AND ISIS IS ON THE
RUN, WHAT HE'S DONE IN ONE SHORT
THIS MEMO WILL BE RELEASED.
I AM TOLD IT WILL SHOCK THE
CONSCIENCE.
AN INVESTIGATION FIXED WHEN
CRIMES WERE COMMITTED.
NO WONDER PEOPLE WERE SHOUTING
LOCK HER UP.
IT'S WORSE.
HER PHONEY RUSSIAN DOSSIER TO
SPRY ON DONALD TRUMP AND AN IN
COMING PRESIDENCY.
TO ME IS THE BIGGEST POLITICAL
SCANDAL IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
ELECTIONS AND THAT WOMAN WHO
LOST MISERABLY.
HER.
YOU CAN'T GET OVER THE ELECTION.
WE ARE WAY PAST IT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT AN ELECTION
THAT DONALD TRUMP WON.
IT'S ABOUT DEMOCRACY AND THE
CONSTITUTION.
IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE KNOWING IF
JUSTICE AND DEMOCRACY WERE
SUBVERTED.
YOU THINK WOMAN HAD EVERY
ADVANTAGE.
AND STILL BLEW IT.
PEOPLE WERE TELLING HER, I WAS
IN WISCONSIN AND THERE WERE
TRUMP SIGNS AND NO HILLARY SIGNS
YOU BETTER GET OUT.